Mariah Carey she's my number one
Brazilian singer Anita dishes on the
women that inspired her upcoming album
kisses out April 5th yeah I started
singing in the church with my
grandfather and um I was born with this
you know singing and singing Mariah
Carey cuz my aunts they're crazy about
Mariah so she was the first singer I've
listened to when I was I don't know 1/2
years old maybe and I always I was
always crazy about music and I always
told my mom that I was gonna be a singer
and saying everywhere and I started in
the church with my grandpa which is
pretty cool cuz in Brazil if you don't
have money it's kind of hard for you to
learn art stuff language it's not easy
so the church helped me with this all I
know about music it was there like seven
or eight years singing in the church
they had ten personalities different
personalities in this album I have a lot
of people that made me made me think
about to get into that side like for
example I grow up listening to Mariah
Carey she's my number one one one or
number zero it's so wonderful she taught
me how to sing she was the first person
I've ever listened to in my life so
Mariah Carey when I sing the romantic
parts it's I she gets me inspired and
when I want to be strong I think about
Beyonce when I want to be sexy and kind
of have this boy acted to and think of a
Rihanna and when I want to have this
like this teenage but sexy teenage stuff
and an funny way to be your think about
Ariana Grande's
I think that every every woman when I
when I want to get my sarcastic part I
think about cardi B I love her so much
I think that each woman has something to
show us to teach us
Anita teased her favorite songs on the
album including banana a saucy collab
with latina singer Becky G so this song
is the sarcastic thing we have double
science and the lyrics it's the video is
colorful it's sexy but at the same time
it's like it's funny so it's not a heavy
sexy thing and I think it matches with
her with the way she is and I really
like her she's pretty she has the
attitude and she's funny and I
definitely want it a women for the Latin
world to be with me in this album
because I think it's important to show
them to everyone basically and the urban
side of the Latin music they it's so
many so many man and it's important to
have women and together to show to show
everybody that when we are together we
are powerful we're stronger and she has
the same thoughts in her mind so that's
why I invited her
all of the songs are really really good
none of the songs are just to feel full
the album you know just to be there and
just plus one more song all of them were
kind of really great so on it's hard
it's a sad one I like I like poquito and
slowly I like banana with Becky G and I
like the one with Snoop Dogg a lot too I
think people are gonna like more this
three songs so this album I I mean I
think it's the most risk paying I've
ever done in my career because I'm
mixing the three language that I speak
which is Spanish Portuguese and English
[Music]
Prince Royce is also making an
appearance not only in a song on kisses
but in their steamy music video for Rosa
the name of the song was boy Prince
Rises ros rosa means waists this song
was made for it was a match of brazilian
producers and songwriters from the latin
side the spanish side and this one is
really sensual the the beat is sensual
the lyrics are essential so we
definitely need to do essential things
so the name is rosa and you used a lot
of grills in the way and and the video
matches a lot with the weather lyrics or
is really essential in deep stuff but
Anita and Royce keep things professional
the pair has collaborated together in
the past and Royce recently tied the
knot we were talking about it as doing
the song and the video artists is my
makeup artist so it's kind of close
thanks and yeah I'm really happy for
this
[Music]